et après avoir fait valoir ses arguments
et ses diverses auditoire dans la
journée le premier ministre s'est amené
au grand valider ses conceptions québec
et la foule il y a réservé une ovation
le couviour
[Applaudissements]
nous voulons du changement nous mettons
nos sièges en jeu pour avoir du
mouvement
la tendance des résultats recueillis
depuis quelques minutes par radio canada
laisse voir que l'option du non
l'emportera
ça fait mal plus profondément que
n'importe quelle défaite électorale
chez de kw h par an
il plaira nous et on donne la balle
vient d'être envoyé dans le camp
fédéraliste
après des semaines de campagne
référendaire le peuple a parlé et qui
vector choisi majoritairement de rejeter
la souveraineté-association et d'opter
pour la voie de la fidélité au canada à
mes compatriotes du québec
blessé par la défaite je veux simplement
dire que nous sortons tous un peu
perdante de ce référendum
faut dire que ce 20 mai 81 restera
peut-être comme un des derniers sursaut
du vieux québec qu'il faut respecter
on est une famille très évidemment
encore dirigé à ce point de vue là